tonight marks the start of that
much-anticipated Amazon Amazon rather
prime day for 30 hours members of
Amazon's Prime service in 13 countries
including the US can take advantage of
hundreds of thousands of deal now this
is the third year for this event and
amazon is offering sales exclusive to
voice ordering on its Alexa enabled
devices like echo this is a new thing
Dan Ackerman from our partners at scene
it is here to explain then good morning
morning to you guys so I know people
were already planning Christmas shopping
in July can it possibly live up to all
the hype because it's a lot of hype out
there but there is a lot of hype and
just like Black Friday never quiet you
know lives up to the hype there are a
couple of specific things that are
always you know a pretty good deal but
people for the last couple of prime days
look through it all they go okay you
know that was all right I'm not super
excited but they signed up a lot of new
Prime members and that's what they want
that's what they wanted 99 bucks a year
and you know they've sell a lot of stuff
and people occasionally find something
they're looking for and what I think is
genius they're offering you a free
subscription if you do it today that'll
last for a month right you can always
get the free trial so you can sign up as
a prime tile member and you get access
to the video and everything and all the
other features and frankly you're likely
to just keep it okay and you get special
deals if you go through Alexa or echo
now that's the interesting thing this
year they're using that that Alexa that
the Dodd and the big echo and the new
show as kind of a Trojan horse for
getting voice ordering into the home
where you just literally call out what
you want to buy and then it's ordered
and shipped to your house so now you can
ask Alexa and every time I say that
people's Alexa's probably going off in
their homes you know what are your deals
today and it'll give you some stuff you
can say yes I want that no I don't want
that I think all of us already have
Amazon Prime so the question is what
additional deals will be out there for
us today
hmm well the stuff on the Amazon
products things like the echo and the
tablets they make which are all pretty
darn good and they used to get pretty
steep discounts for prime day they've
also promised some good TV deals this
year and that's the one sort of big
expensive item everyone always waits for
a sale and almost nobody pays a regular
retail for a TV usually you'd wait for
Black Friday if you're looking to get a
big TV this might be the day for that do
other companies not have to do their own
version of Amazon Prime it's huge
counter-programming it away just like
everyone has a Black Friday sale other
stores can't call it a prime day sale
but they say they're having you know
July 11th you know deals and some of
them from Ana tagline like no membership
require
so you don't need the f99 Valley Bob has
been doing this for a number of years
huge payday for them and you know an
eBay is doing it and I've gotten so many
emails from everybody from Lowe's to
Best Buy promoting you know sales this
week that I meant to to counter program
that that prime day stuff so in the
teaser we said you might be disappointed
why would you be disappointed well I
think there's a discoverability problem
where you go to the Amazon website and
you just click through all this stuff
and it's not really anything you're
specifically interested in if there's
one thing you're looking for maybe to be
on sale maybe it won't you can put it on
a watch list or some third-party apps
you can use that will track prices for
you but but it's a lot of stuff to dig
through to find the one or two bits ago
okay my son wants the Under Armour
Jordan speith shoes golf shoes will
those be on sale today that's exactly
the thing we can work on and my son has
the Alexa so he may already be talking
to alexa please order have I asked the
likes of what was on sale yesterday and
I got a giant box of toilet paper and
Clif bars so I was not very excited
yesterday you used toilet pay on
McMartin II on what March of Emma's on
it that's right that's good to know
about you thank you where you gonna put
all those Christmas gifts your order